you're also a musical person because I'm
doing I want to do the best I can to get
you another job you that's what I do you
sing you dance is that correct well I
can't dance I won't dance for you now
because it is too sexual and harrowing
when I dance but I do I actually do
write music well actually I've written
one song I wrote one song what's it like
to sing it right now
it's about me my name is Claudia yeah
I'm from a neighborhood in Sydney called
glebe and thank you yes you definitely
are not from bleed and I wrote it one
day you know Paul McCartney from the
Beatles yes I know Paul McCartney from
the Beatles so like he wrote that song
yesterday and that just sort of came to
him in a dream he wake up one day in the
melody when he's losing his head so this
is pretty much like that and it's the
same quality okay and it's about me
walking through glee with a pie in my
hand in Australia we have meat pies that
are the size of your hand I just don't
want you to picture like an apple pie in
American Pie I want you to picture a
small Australian meat pie
so glebe hi Claudia
that's pretty much what I need to know
for the song and now we're ready to go
also I have quite a high haunting
singing voice so keep your ears out for
that here we go there we go I walk
through Glee with a pie in my hand I
have a lot to give I walk through clean
with my heart on my sleeve
I have a lot of life to live because I'm
Claudia Claudia Claudia of clean
Steven Spielberg once the [ __ ] that in
yes if one of the burg sees that they're
gonna put you in their movie